حتى الان نحن بانتظار توضيحات من الجانب
الروسي طبعا سواء كان من وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه او من حول هذا الهجوم المكثف الذي
نفذته روسيا على اوكرانيا ولكن نستطيع ان
نستخلص مما جرى خلال الايام السابقه وبسبب
الضغوط الكبيره في مدينه كما تحدث اليوم
القائم بالاعمال رئيس جمهوريه دونيسك
الانفصاليه الذي تحدث ان الوضع في باخموت
هو سيء وصعب للغايه وبالتالي تم اعاده
تجمع القوات العسكريه هناك وبالتالي قد
يكون هناك تكثيف لهذه الهجمات اولا
لاستهداف مخازن الاسلحه لدى
اوكرانيا وهذا على خلفيه ايضا اسقاط يوم
امس الصاروخ المجنح البريطاني الفرنسي
الصنع الذي تم اسقاده لاول مره من قبل
وزاره الدفاع والتي تقوم بريطانيا الان
التي تحدثت بريطانيا عن انها ستقوم بتزويد
اوكرانيا به ولكن الجانب الروسي كان قد
تحدث ايضا عن هذه الاسلحه كانت قد وصلت
وان هذا القرار تم اتخاده قبيل قبيله يوم
امس بالتالي ان هذه الاسلحه وصلت منذ فتره
طويله وبدات اوكرانيا باستخدامها لذلك
هناك افتراض بان تقوم روسيا بتكثيف
الضربات لاستهداف الشحنات الاسلحه التي
تصل الى اوكرانيا احمد من مصر كنت معنا
ممارسه العربيه
شكرا لك
العربيه بان الجيش الاوكراني استهدف مدينه
دونيسكو وضوحيها بثلاثمائه وتسعه صواريخ
وقذائف بدفعيه ما اسفر عن مقتل شخص واصابه
التسعه اخرين بجروح كما ادى قصفه الى
الضروري عشره ابنيه سكنيه وخمسه مرافق
بناء تحتيه وبينما يتواصل القتال في جبهه
واشنطن بوست زعم انه عرض على معلومات حول
مواقع القوات الروسيه مقابل انسحابها وصف
بريجوج الى التقرير بالمضحك مرجحا ان يكون
افراد من النخبه الروسيه وراء تسريبه اما
الكرملين فوصف المعلومات التي نشرتها
واشنطن بوست بالمضلله
وفي اول اعتراف رسمي لبدء هجوم الربيع كشف
قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه عن تقدم
قوات بلاده في باخد هجمات عده على المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا شمال وشرق البلاد
مسجد من التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
ليست مشاهد من فيلم بل الاختراق خطوط دفاع
الجيش الروسي على اطراف ضخمه خطوط قال
قائد قوه فاجنر ان الجنود الروسي يفيرون
منها
فوفق لقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
فان قواته تتقدم في باخمه كاول نجاح في
الهجوم الايام القليله الماضيه اظهرت انه
يمكننا المضي قدما وتدمير العدو حتى في
مثل هذه الظروف الصعبه للغايه نقاتل
بموارد اقل من العدو وفي الوقت نفسه ننجح
في تدمير خططه
تصريح سيرسكي يعتبر اول اعتراف رسمي ببدء
هجوم الربيع هجوم تقول المعلومات انه لا
يقتصر على فقط فالقوه الاوكرانيه قصفت
اراضي دانيتسكي 90 مره خلال الاربع
والعشرين ساعه الماضيه وفي المجموع اطلقت
500 وسته عشره قذيفه على المنطقه التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا من جانبها اعترفت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بمقتل اثنين من قادتها
العسكريين شرق اوكرانيا اثناء اختراق
القوات الاوكرانيه الدفاعات الروسيه في
باخموت موسكو اعترفت ايضا بان قواتها
تراجعت في شمال المدينه وسط تكثيف للهجمات
الاوكرانيه في تقرير لوزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه فان مسيرات شنت هجوما على
قاعده جويه روسيه على بعد 150 كيلومترا
شمال الحدود الاوكرانيه في الثالث من مايو
ورجحت الوزاره في التقرير ان يكون الهجوم
اضر باحدى طائرات النقل الثقيل حيث لعبت
القاعده الروسيه دورا رئيسيا في التقدم
الذي احرزته موسكو في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
عاد كون القاعده تستخدمها لاطلاق المسيرات
الايرانيه باتجاه كيف
وبين تكتم كييف على بدء الهجوم وما تقوله
المعلومات على الارض تبدو افاده قائد قوات
فاجنر الاخيره اقرب للواقع حين قال كيف
حصلت على الاسلحه
وبدات هجومها
قالت مجره الامريكيه ان المال المخصص
للدعم العسكري من واشنطن
وذكرت المجلان الاموال التي خصصتها
الولايات المتحده لاجل التمويه العسكري
لاوكراني
ستنضم في الاشهر المقبله وصدق قلق من بعض
المرشدين المشرعين من عدم التمديد مستقبلا
مشيرا الى انه لم يتبقى الان سوى سته
مليارات دولار من حزمه المساعدات التي
بلغت قيمتها 48 مليار دولار والتي اقرها
الكونجرس الامريكي لاوكرانيا في ديسمبر
الماضي
نشر شبكه
ان وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
تسعى لتجنيد الروس غير الاراضيين عن
سياسات الرئيس الروسي
واشارت الشبكه الى ان سي اي تامل في
التواصل مع عاملين في مجالات الاستخبارات
والدبلوماسيه والعلوم والتكنولوجيا
ومجالات اخرى وانها مهتمه بكل انواع
الاستخبارات بما فيها السياسيه
والاقتصاديه
تناقش وزيره انتقال الطاقه الفرنسيه في
باريس اليوم تناقش مع نظرائها من 14 دوله
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا سبل الحد
من الاعتماد النووي على روسيا وسيناقش
وزراء الطاقه في اطار التحالف الدول
الاوروبيه للطاقه الذريه الذي انشئ في
مارس السول الممكنه للتعزيز استقلال
اوروبا عن روسيا لاسيما في مساله الوقود
النووي والتي لا يمكن القيام بها بين عشيه
وضحاها لان بعض الدول لديها محطات طاقه
روسيه على اراضها وهذا يزيد الاعتماد على
الوقود من روسيا يذكر ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يستورد العام الماضي وقود النووي من روسيا
بمبلغ مليار يورو حسب صحيفه لوفيجارو
نشاتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
في سباق الرئاسي التركي حزب اردوغان يقي-
يقيم نتائج وكالجدار يطيح بنائمه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد وفي متابعه
السباق الرئاسي التركي قال مراقبون لمنظمه
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا للمؤسسات
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان ان لجنه العليا
للانتخابات في تركيا اظهرت انها لا تتمتع
بالشفافيه في ادارتها للانتخابات الاخيره
مؤكده ان التغطيه الاعلاميه الحكوميه
المنحازه للانتخابات تعد مبعث قلق على حد
قولهم واعتبرت المنظمه ان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان والحزب الحاكم تمتع بامتيازات غير
مباره مقارنه باحزاب المعارضه مؤكده ان
الاحزاب المعارضه واجهت ظروفا غير متكافئه
اثناء حملتها الانتخابيه لكن المنظمه
ارشادت في الوقت ذاته بالاقبال الكبير
الذي اعتبرت انه مؤشر واضح للروح
الديمقراطيه القويه
عقدت اللجنه التنفيريه المركزيه لحزب
العداله والتنميه التركي اجتماعا برئاسه
زعيم الحزب الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في
العاصمه انقره الاجتماع مشاهدينا الذي
انعقد بعيدا عن وسائل الاعلام واستغرق
ثلاث ساعات خصص لتقييم الانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئاسيه الاخيره التي شهدتها
تركيا كما ناقشت تحضيرات اللازمه للجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات في الثامن والعشرين
من مايو جاري
وكان اردوغان قال في بيان الله ان شعبه
انجز انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه والتي تعد
على حد وصفه واحده من الانتخابات الاكثر
مشاركه في تاريخ تركيا مؤكدا ان الاصوات
التي حصل عليها
ستضاعف وسيشهد فوزا تاريخيا في جوله
الاعاده
وبخصوص منافس اردوغان كما
افادت مصادر تركيا معارضه انه طلب من
نائبه الاستقاله بسبب ادائه السلبي في
الانتخابات
نشر مقطع فيديو على حسابه في تويتر قال
فيه انه سيقاتل حتى النهايه على حد وصفه
متابع
ين
اتصور ان اردوغان يجب ان يفوز لو فاز حزب
الشعب الجمهوري ستحل علينا نكبه الشعب
سيرى حاله الفوضى والغموض خلال الفتره
القادمه وسيعود الانتخاب اردوغان في
الجوله الثانيه
لا اعرف ان كان هناك تزوير ام لا لا اعتقد
ان هناك تزوير او ما شابه لان المعارضه
وفرت كوادر رقابه مشدده وفي الجوله
الثانيه ساصوت من جديد لكليتش دار اوغلو
يعني
التحالفات الانتخابيه المتداخله كانت
السبب وراء الذهاب نحو جوله ثانيه بالنسبه
لنا الهدف هو تحقيق الافضل من اجل تركيا
وشعبها
كنت امل احراز حزب العداله والتنميه
الفوزه من الجوله الاولى ونتمنى الفوز في
الجوله القادمه حماسنا لم يخمد ولن يخبو
اصوات مرشح الاجداد سنان اوغان ستتجه لحزب
العداله والتنميه وهذا ما سيكسب حزب
العداله والتنميه فرصه الفوز بالرئاسه
لرجب طيب اردوغان ليس هناك اي تزوير ولا
اصدق هذه الادعاءات ربما حدثت بعض
الخروقات لكن بطبيعه الحال تم التصدي لها
وهذه عمليه انتخابيه كبيره بالطبع ستكون
هناك بعض الصعوبات
من اسطنبول مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا مفرد
العربيه طاهر بركه ومن انقره موفضه
العربيه فاطمه فهد اهلا بكم الطاهر وفاطمه
وابدا معك طاهر ويبدو ان اردوغانو عازماني
على استغلال كل دقيقه الاستعداد ليوم 28
من مايو ما الذي يراهن عليه الرجلان طاهر
اهلا بك احمد اهلا بفاطمه وبالمشاهدين
بدون شك ما يراهن عليه اردوغان ما يعتبره
شبه نصر حققه في الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات ان كان في الرئاسيات ولو لم
يظفر بخمسين زائدا واحدا او في
البرلمانيات التي فازت فيها الموالاه يعول
على الاسبوعين المتبقيين قبل جوله الاعاده
التي تشهدها تركيا للمره الاولى في
تاريخها دعني انقل لك بعض يعني مما تقوله
الصحف هذا الصباح من المواليه والمعارضه
لاضعك ايضا في صوره النقاش الحاد الدائر
بين الطرفين في هذه الصبيحه صحيفه صباح
المواليه تقول المواطن صوت للانجازات وليس
للثرثره وهكذا سيقرر في جوله الاعاده
حريات تقول تعرفنا على جوله الاعاده لاول
مره في تاريخ ديمقراطيتنا تركيا المواليه
تقول هزيمه الطاوله السداسيه في اشاره الى
المعارضه صحيفه اكشام المواليه الفائز هو
الديمقراطيه التركيه اما يصحف المعارضه
مثل جمهوريه فقالت سنفوز مع علامه تعجب
اما صحيفه سوزو فكانت اكثر قسوه على
الموالات وعلى بعض الناخبين من الذين
صوتوا للموالاه قالت يبدو ان الشعب شبعان
شبعان احمد باللغه التركيه تعني توك
والسياره التي انتجتها تركيا بصناعه محليه
وهي حديثه تعني ولكن بالغين وليس بالكاف
هنا تحاول سوزو والمعارضه الاستهزاء
باستخدام كلمه وهناك هجوم في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من قبل الموالات على
هذه التعابير التي تستخدمها المعارضه
وكانه استهزاء بالانجازات التركيه طبعا
صحيفه قرار المعارضه ايضا قالت امامنا
اسبوعان طويلان اما ياني تشاك القوميه
المعار تقول الاعين تترقب قرار القوميين
اما بالنسبه الى السوشيال ميديا وتويتر
فيتصدر لا يزال يتصدر سنان اوغان الذي
ينتظر قراره بعدما بدا المفاوضات مع
الجانبين من سيدعم اضافه الى اوميت اوزداج
رئيس حزب الظفر حليف سنان اوغان في تحالف
الاجداد ولكن يعني 240 الفا يتصدر سنان
اوغام على تويتر
تخيل انه لم يستطع رغم انه حليف سنان
اوغان الذي تدور كل الاحاديث عنه الان لم
يستطع ان يظفر وهو رئيس حزب الظفر بمقعد
في البرلمان لان النسبه التي تحصل عليها
هي
2.23% وهو دون العتبه الانتخابيه اللازمه
اي 7% كان قال اعتذر من الشعب لعدم تمكننا
من تحقيق حلمه بدخول البرلمان واعاده
اللاجئين السوريين انظر الى كل هذه
الملفات واختلاطها في التص وعناوين الصحف
والسوشيال ميديا في تركيا هذا الصباح
في هذه الصحف طاهر يعني هو يجسد حقيقه مدى
التوتر ومدى التنافس الشديد بين الاطراف
المترشحه لهذه الانتخابات لكن طاهر ايضا
منذ الاعلان عن نتائج الاوليه وهناك حاله
يتحدث عنها عن عدم رضا او حاله خيبه امل
لدى جانب المعارضه في سواء على الصعيد
المناصرين او على صعيد القيادات ايضا ربما
انعكس ذلك على في مساله اقاله او استقاله
النائب اوغلو هل اقيل او استقال وما حقيقه
الخلافات بينهما اذا توفرت معلومات حول
ذلك
الواضح مما حصل انه تمت اقالته من قبل
رئيس
مرشح تحالف الامه رئيس حزب رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري
كمال كليتش بسبب ادائه الضعيف في هذه
الانتخابات وهو كان مسؤول بشكل مباشر عن
يعني الاتصالات والاعلام والعلاقات العامه
وبالتالي كان يعني يراهن عليه في هذه
المعركه حاميه الوطيس التي حصلت بدون شك
ربما يعني الكل كل الانظار تتجه الان الى
قادم الايام لنرى اذا ما كان سيحصل تصدعات
اكبر في المعارضه او او في الجهه الاخرى
ولكن بما ان الجهه الاخرى فازت في
البرلمان حتى الان ولو ان المقاعد قد
تتقلص بحكم بعض الانسحابات من التحالف
الرئاسي
فاذا التصدعات قد تحصل الاستقالات في
محاوله لتحسين موقع اهل تحسين شروطه في
هذه المعركه ولكن هل ستكون ايام المقبله
في فتره اسبوعين فقط قادره على ان يكسب
فيها ما خسره في كل الفتره الماضيه خلال
الحمله الانتخابيه والنتائج التي حققها
هذا السؤال كبير هناك تعويض على حاله
الايام المقبله الطاهره في هذه النتائج
نعم
الانتقال لفاطمه فاطمه اهلا بك كيف تبدو
اذا اجواء الاستعدادات للجوله الثانيه في
انقره
استعدادات على
الحملات الانتخابيه مجددا تتعلق على
الشوارع بدانا نرى الحملات الاعلانيه
اللوح الدعائيه ايضا تعود الى شوارع
العاصمه انقره اليوم من المتوقع ان يعلن
كريستار اوغلو عن استراتيجيته للحمله
للانتخابيه في دورتها الثانيه وايضا نتوقع
ان نسمع من محرم انجاب ايضا كلمه له
وخطابا يدعم فيه كليش دار محرم انجي الذي
قال بانه مهما حصل يجب ان تذهب هذه
الحكومه الحاليه اذا هذه من الاخبار
المتوقعه اليوم ان نشهدها في العاصمه
بالنسبه للانتقال للجوله الثانيه احمد
يعني هناك كما تعلم شروط خمسه شروط لسنان
اوغان يطرحها على المرشحين لكي يكسب او
لكي يدلي باصواته لهم طبعا من هذه الشروط
ان تثبيت المواد الاربعه الاولى من
الدستور وضع حد ضد محاوله ازاله القوميه
من الدستور وهو ما تنص عليه الماده 66 على
فكره ويشترط ايضا ترحيل 13 مليون اللاجئ
السوري من تركيا كما يزعم هو رغم ان هذا
الرقم حقيقه غير منطقي
ويريد التخلص من نسبه الفائده المرتفعه
والتضخم وهذا الكارت الذي يضغط به على
الحزب الحاكم ويريد الفصل بين المنظمات
الارهابيه وهياكلها السياسيه الجدير
بالذكر هنا احمد ان اردوغان بالفعل يعمل
الان على هذه الشروط يعني هو ينوي تغيير
الدستور كما قال قبل عام وما زال يكررها
وهو ايضا بدا بالتطبيع مع مع دمشق كما
راينا من اجل من اعاده اللاجئين الى سوريا
وايضا بدا خطوه فعليه لاغلاق حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي ويعني يرى بعض الخبراء هنا في
الداخل التركي احمد بان المشهد السياسي
التركي او ان سنان اوغان والخمسه في المئه
او 5% اكثر بقليل من اصواتهم لن تؤثر
حقيقه كثيرا في الاصوات لانه لانه يرون
بانه نصف هذه الاصوات لن تتجاوب مع سنان
اوغلو ان اختار احد المرشحين او لن يذهبوا
الى الانتخابات كليا اذا يعني سنان اغلب
بعكس ما هو يعتقد يعني يرون المحللين بان
الاصوات التي تنتمي له لن تؤثر حقيقه في
الجوله الثانيه وفي الناخبين
اذا سكتفي بهذا القدر نكون معكم في متابعه
دائما للتطورات الانتخابات في تركيا شكرا
لكم من انقره كنت معنا
طاهر بركه تحياتي طاهر وفاطمه
مشاهدينا مع انتقال المعركه الانتخابيه
التركيه الى جوله ثانيه واقتصارها على
المنافسين كمال بل المتنافسين كما
اردوغان كيف سيسعى كل منهما لحسم السباق
لصالح خلال الاسبوعين المقبلين نتابع
اسبوعان امام رجب الطيب اردوغان ومنافسه
كمال
باستماله الاصوات وكسب المعركه في الجوله
الثانيه
المعارضه برئاسه كيليتشار اوغلو تركز في
سياستها على انهاء حقبه اردوغان
و وحلفاؤه يريدون تغيير النظام الرئاسي
وتقليص صلاحيات الرئيس اغلاق المشاريع
الكبرى مثل قناه اسطنبول وصندوق الثروه
التركي
تحويل البلاد الى منطقه عازله وزياده عدد
مراكز اعاده اللاجئين واعاده السوريين
انهاء نظام ايداع الليره المحمي واعفاء
الشباب من رسوم جواز السفر وعود اردوغان
اردوغان يركز على سياسه دعم فئه الشباب
داخليا وقطاع التعليم وزياده اشراك المراه
في القوه العامله
وعود بتدابير جديده لمعالجه التضخم
وانهيار الليره التركيه
خارجيا يريد اردوغان اتباع سياسه الانفتاح
اكثر على الدول المنطقه والعالم
السباق بين المتنافسين في المرحله القادمه
يتطلب استقطاب اصوات نخيبي الخارجي من
الجوله الاولى
سنان اوغان ومحرم انجا قد يشكلان ورقه
الفوز في الجوله القادمه بالتحالف مع
احدهما
اشتباكات عديده مشاهدينا شهدتها مناطق في
الخرطوم حيث افاد مراس العربي عن وقوع
الشبكات عنيفه بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم منها حي المعموره وحي
الرياض وجبر جنوب العاصمه هذا وشهد
السودان على مدى الشهر الماضي قتالا عنيفا
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه في صراع
الطرفين على السلطه
صباحا
على بعد 850 كيلو مترا نحو الشرق تتكئ
المدينه على ساحل البحر الاحمر
خلافا لموقعها الاستراتيجي بدات الانظار
تتجه نحوها كمدينه لا تقل اهميه عن
العاصمه الخرطوم عن كثب ظل محمد الحسن
شجيره الباحث في شؤون شرق السودان يتابع
تداعيات ما يحدث في الخرطوم على واقع
مدينه بورسودان بالنسبه اليه فان المدينه
مهيئه للتعامل مع المتغيرات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والاداريه في البلاد مؤهله من
ناحيه الاقامه من ناحيه الاقتصاد نحت
التجاره من ناحيه البنيات التحتيه برزان
مؤهله تكون المدينه
الاداريه الاولى بعد الخرطوم طيب عندها
مطار دولي وعندها ميناء مطيله على كل هذا
الساحل
تكتسبان اهميتها من كونها تستوعب الميناء
البحري الرئيس في البلاد كما ظلت خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه المنفذ الاهم لاجلاء
رعايه دول الاجنبيه من السودان جراء
الاوضاع الامنيه
هنا مطار بورتسودان الدولي بقرار من مجلس
الوزراء السوداني اصبح احد المطارات
المحدده لاستقبال المساعدات الانسانيه
الدوليه من مطار يستقبل عددا قليلا من
الطائرات اضحى بسبب الحرب امام واقع جديد
المطار
يعني كيف نفسه على المتغيرات دي بيجينا
نتعامل مع كل انواع الطائرات يعني حتى
الطائرات العسكريه من طراسيس 17 هي طيارات
ضخمه جدا نقله عسكريه المطار قدر يوفر لي
المساحات الزمنيه ويوفر لها
الاطفاء والانغاز تحتاجيه ولا قدر الليزر
حصل الكارثه
في الاستقرار الامني الذي تشهده المدينه
جعل وزارات ومؤسسات رسميه تباشر مهامها من
بورتسودان فالمدينه ورغم الوضع الامني ما
تزال موانئها البحريه تستقبل السلع
الاستراتيجيه والمواد البترونيه
بتامين الاقوات المسلحه
للولايات نحن شايفين في مشكله كبيره الان
نزيد في حجم المعادله البتروليه لم تدخل
الموسم الزراعي لمن الهواجس الان شغلانه
الان متحركه بصوره ممتازه الظرف
الاستثنائي الذي تمر به البلاد فرض واقعا
جديدا على مختلف المدن الاف الاسري لجات
بسبب الحرب الى بورسودان والعديد من
الوزارات الاتحاديه وسفارات استانفت
نشاطها من هنا ما يجعل المدينه الساحليه
امام اختبار صعب للتعامل مع كل هذه
المتغيرات نزار الب غداوي العربيه مدينه
بورسودان شرقيه السودان
اقتحمت القوات الاسرائيليه صباح اليوم
مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب غرب اريحا حيث تحاصر
القوات الاسرائيليه منزلا وتطالب من فيه
بتسليم انفسهم الاقتحام الاسرائيلي
مشاهدين للمخيم اسفر عن اصابه فلسطيني
برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي والعشرات ايضا
بالاختناق بالغاز كما اعتقلت القوات
الاسرائيليه سته شبان فلسطينيين خلال
الاقتحام
نشاطنا مستمر وفيها بعض الفاصل
في تونس الحكم بسجن زعيم حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي بتهمه تمجيد الارهاب
[موسيقى]
هجوم روسي ضخم يستهدف كييفو لتجنيد روس
غير راضيين عن سياسه بوتين
منظمه اوروبيه تشكك في شفافيه انتخابات
تركيا
جنوب الخرطوم وبورسودان تستقبل الاف
الفارين
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم مخيم عقبه جبر
جنوب غرب اريحا وتعتقل سته شبان فلسطينيين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في تونس سقطت
محكمه مختصه في قضايا الارهاب بسجن راشد
الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه لمده عام
وتغريمه وذكرت المحكمه ان الغنوشي اودين
غيابيا لوصف الاجهزه الامنيه بالطواغيت
الامر الذي يندرج ضمن افعال مجرمه وفقا
للقانون
من تونس مشاهدينا معنا الصحفيين حمداوي
اهلا بك نسرين وتفاصيل اوفى عن هذا الحكم
الصادر بحق راشد الغنوشي وابرز ردود الفعل
حوله
نعم مرحبا في الحقيقه زعيم حركه النهضه
راشد الغنوشي اصبح مودان رسميا بمقتضى حكم
الابتدائي صادر اليوم امس عن المحكمه
الابتدائيه في تونس بتهمه تمجيد الارهاب
بعدما استعمل لفظ تواقيت الذي يمجد
الارهاب خلال تابين احد قيادات حركه
النهضه في شهر 2 من سنه 2022
في جهه قابس بالجنوب التونسي بعد ذلك تقدم
احد القيادات الامنيه بشكايه ضد راشد
الغنوشي مما دفع بالقضاء الى فاتح تحقيق
تم على اثره ادانه الغنوشي بسنه سجن كامله
بالاضافه الى تغريمه بخطيه ماليه قدرها
1000 دينار تونسي اي ما يعادل حوالي 300
دولار راشد الغنوشي ليست هذه القضيه
الاولى التي يقبع على اثرها في السجن فهو
الان حاليا موضع على ذمه قضيه تحقيقيه
تتعلق بتصريحات كان ادلى بها خلال اجتماع
لجبهه الخلاص الوطني التي تعد حركه النهضه
احد ابرز عمدتها
والذين يعارضون في الحقيقه اجراءات الخامس
والعشرين مليون
ورئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد ردود الفعل
الاوليه صدرت بالاساس عن جبهه الخلاص التي
اكدت ان السلطه الحاليه لم تجد اي تهمه
لراشد الغنوشي فتولت قالت ان هذه التهمه
كيديه لكن القضاء التونسي قال كلمته وفقا
لقانون الارهاب الصادر منذ سنه 2015 والذي
صادق عليه البرلمان الذي كانت حركه النهضه
احد اكبر كتله ايضا حركه النهضه بدورها
كانت اصدرت امسا بيان نددت فيه بهذا بهذا
الحكم القضائي وقالت ان تونس على وشك
الانهيار الاجتماعي نعم
هل عرف او عرفت المده التي سيقضيها في
السجن في على ذمه هذه القضيه وفي القضيه
الاخرى ايضا
في الحقيقه راشد الغنوشي الان مازال مود
على ذمه التحقيق ولم تصدر الى حد الان
احكام ابتدائيه او احكام باته في كل
القضايا المرفوعه ضده سواء تلك المتعلقه
بما يعرف اعلاميا بقضيه انسيلو او حتى
بالقضايا المتعلقه بالارهاب وتسير الشباب
وخاصه ما يعرفوا بالجهاز السري لحركه
النهضه الاسلاميه في تونس كل هذه القضايا
ما زالت طور التحقيق لدى القضاء التونسي
ولم تصدر في اي منها اي احكام ابتدائيه
نعم اللافت ايضا ان الغنوشي يعني الرفض
حضور المحاكمه الاخيره وعلى اثرها اصدرت
المحكمه الحكمه غيابيا هل هناك معلومات
حول دوافعه او مبرراته
نعم بالفعل رشد الغنوشي يقول انه لن يمثل
بعد الان امام القضاء التونسي باعتبار انه
يرى ان كل القضايا المرفوعه ضده هي قضايا
كيديه لكن ذلك لا يمنع المحاكمه في
الحقيقه فله حريه اختيار عدم الوثول امام
هيئه المحكمه لكن القضيه ما زالت جاريه
ضده رغم انه مازال مودعا بالسجن بالمرنجيه
في قرب العاصمه تونس وهنالك ربما عشرات
القضايا التي يحاكم فيها راشد الغنوشي
حاليا مضافه الى عدد كبير ايضا من قيادات
حركه النهضه نعم شكرا لك من تونس معنا
الصحفيه نسرين حمداوي تحيه نسرين
بين انعقاد القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين في جده نقل صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
عن مصادر الدبلوماسيه غربيه توقعاتها بان
تتعامل القمه العربيه مع جمله من تطورات
الدوليه والاقليميه الحساسه فعل الصعيد
الدولي شهدت الحرب في اوكرانيا تصعيدا
كبيرا الدائره تدهور غير مسبوق في
العلاقات الغربيه الروسيه بل العرب
الغربيه الروسيه
وسياسيه اقليميا مشاهدينا اشارت المصادر
الى البيان السعودي الايراني الصيني الذي
فتح الباب امام عوده العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه معتبره انه سيفتح الباب لبحث
ملفات اخرى تعتبر تعتبر ايران بل تعتبر
ايران معنيه مباشره فيها وفي ملف سوريا
اكدت المصادر ان الدول الغربي ستراقب
مرحله ما بعد العوده وما اذا كانت ستتحرك
للقيام بخطوات ايجابيه في اتجاه الحل
السياسي وعوده اللاجئين وغيرها من ملفات
هذا ولم يستبعد المصدر الصحيفه ان تترك
تطورات الدوليه والاقليميه تاثيرها على
صياغه بعض البنود التي ستصدر عن القمه
في تطورات الازمه السياسيه في باكستان
قررت لجنه الامن القومي في الحكومه
الباكستانيه والتي تضم كبار الوزارات
وقاده الجيش والاستخبارات قررت عقد
اجتماعات لبحث تطورات الازمه السياسيه
والاوضاع الامنيه في البلاد كما ياتي
الاجتماع المقرر عقب تنديد البرلمان
باعمال العنف التي ثلاث اعتقال رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمرا خان وكذلك عقب بيان
الجيش الذي توعد من خلاله مخاططي ومنفذي
الهجمات بالمحاكمه وفق القوانين المدنيه
والعسكريه هذا ونفى عمران خان اي صله له
او لحزمه باعمال الشغب ويتهم في المقابل
عناصر في الامن بافتعالها لتبرير الحمل
الامنيه ضد قاده ونشطاء حزبه
هوس تيك توك يحصد حياه الطفل اللبناني
محمد الاسطنبولي مجموعه من الشبان يركضون
ويلبسون ثيابا مخيفه ويحملون سيوفا في
ايديهم في حديقه صغيره مخصصه للاطفال خلال
تصوير فيديو بغيه نشره على التطبيق تسبب
في وفاه طفل بعد ان توقف قلبه من الخوف
ووقعت الماساه
حيث كان الطفل يلعب في منطقه قريبه من
منزله
وشاهد شابا وشابتين يرتدون اقنعه مرعبه
وملابس سوداء يحملون السيوف وبداوا بتمثيل
مشهد مرعب
لمتابعهم على حساباتهم عبر تطبيق تيك توك
التفاصيل
كانت هناك عم تلبس المقنع ولبس سوداء
حمض عم يلعب بها
دغري خاف
هذه ليست مشاهد من فيلم رعب بل حادثه
حقيقيه ادت الى وفاه الاخ التوام لعلي ابن
السته اعوام
في حديقه حاره سور القديمه لفظ محمد
انفاسه الاخيره فمجموعه من شابين وفتاتين
قررت تمثيل مشاهد رعب في فسحه مخصصه
للاطفال لاطحاق متابعيها على تيك توك
فكانت النتيجه وفاه طفل لم يتحمل قلبه
مشاهده اشخاص باقنعه وملابس سوداء شاهرين
سيوفا حديديه
كانوا هناك ماشيين عم يركضوا وراه بصوص
لحدا يديك الزروبي وقف قلبه
طب هو
اشياء مرعبه اغاني مرعبه
اطلب من الله يرد حق امه
لانه ابن نهار ومرته انهارت مرته مش عم
تصحى مش معقول يصير فيها هاي بسببه فلوسنا
ابن سبع سنين
اهمال اهمال المسؤولين هاي اهمال مسؤولين
مش ناس هنا
رغم ان البعض قد يصف ما حدث بالقضاء
والقدر الا ان الاهالي يصرون على محاسبه
الشبان الذين اتوا من قرى مجاوره فاوقفوا
بتهمه التسبب بالقتل
نحن الهدف انه يكونوا درس لاي شيء بدهم
يعملوهن او غيرهن يعني غيرهم يتعلم انه
ياخذوا بالعين الاعتبار السلام العامه
لموقع التصوير يكون في السلام العام يعني
ما نستلشي بحياه الاولاد بحياه الكبار شيء
مرعب له اماكن مساحه اللعب هذه توارثها
الابناء عن الاباء وهي امنه للاطفال خاصه
وانها تقع وسط منازلهم التي تبعد دقائق عن
مكان وقوع الحادثه التي هزت لبنان الكلام
لن يخفف من وقع الفاجعه لكن تسليط الضوء
على القضيه يبقى درسا شبان اتخذوا من
وسائل التواصل وسيله لكسب مشاهدات على
حساب الاخرين
اصدر السلطات الامريكيه مذكره استدعاء بحق
ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيسلا
في قضيه مصرف جيب
المتهم بمساعده ملياردير في تنظيم شبكه
لتهريب البشر وتشير وثائق القضائيه التي
تم نشرها الى ان السلطات جزر
الامريكيه حاولت تسليم ماسك مذكره استدعاء
صادره في 28 من ابريل للاشتباه قد يكون
اشار الى ايلون ماسك كزبون لمصرف لمصرف
جيب مارجان وقال السلطات الجزر فيرجن انها
تحاول تحديد مكان ايلون ماسك واتصلت باحد
محاميه
انا مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز العناوين
هجوم روسي ضخم يستهدف كييف هو سي اي 8
تخطط لتجنيد روس غير اراضين عن سياسه
بوتين
منظمات اوروبيه تشكك في شفافيه انتخابات
تركيا
بسبب النتائج
اشتباكات عنيفه تتجدد في مناطق متفرقه
جنوب الخرطوم وبورسودان تستقبل الاف الفري
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم مخيم عقبه جبر
جنوب غرب اريحا وتعتقل سته شبان فلسطينيين
مشاهدينا كونوا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات